- [Instructor] What we're going
to do in this video is look
at all of the ways of describing
how to translate a point
and then to actually translate that point
on our coordinate plane.
So, for example, they say
plot the image of point P
under a translation by
five units to the left
and
three units up.
So let's just do that at first,
and then we're gonna
think about other ways
of describing this.
So we want to go five units to the left.
So we start right over here.
We're gonna go one, two, three,
four, five units to the left,
and then we're gonna go three units up.
So that's going to be one, two, three.
And so the image of point P,
I guess, would show up right over here,
after this translation described this way.
Now, there are other ways
that you could describe this translation.
Here, we described it
just in plain English,
by five units to the
left and three units up.
But you could, and this will look fancy,
but, as we'll see, it's
hopefully a pretty intuitive way
to describe a translation.
You could say, look, I'm
gonna take some point
with the coordinates x comma y.
And the x coordinate tells
me what's my coordinate
in the horizontal direction
to the left or the right.
And so I want that to be five less.
So I would say x minus five
comma
y.
And what do we do to the y coordinate?
Well, we're going to increase it by three.
We're going to translate three units up,
so y
plus three.
So all this is saying is whatever x
and y coordinates you have,
this translation will make
you take five from the x.
That's what, meaning this is,
this right over here, is five units
to the left.
And then this right over here,
is saying three
units up.
Increase your y coordinate by three.
Decrease your x coordinate by five.
And so let's just test this out
with this particular coordinate,
with this particular point.
So at this point right over here,
P has the coordinates,
its x coordinate is three,
and its y coordinate is negative four.
So let's see how that works.
If I have three comma negative four,
and I want to apply this translation,
what happens?
Well, let me just do my coordinates.
And so I started off with
three and negative four,
and I'm going to subtract
five from the three.
So subtract five here, we
see that right over there,
and we're going to add three to the y.
So notice, well, instead of
an x, now I have a three.
Instead of an x, now I have a three.
Instead of a y, now I
have a negative four.
And so another way of writing this,
we're going from three comma negative four
to three minus five is negative two,
and negative four plus
three is negative one.
So what are the coordinates
right over here?
Well, the coordinate
of this point is indeed
negative two comma negative one.
So notice how this,
I guess you could say this formula,
the algebraic formula that shows
how we map our coordinates,
how it's able to draw the connection
between the coordinates.
And so you'll see questions
where they'll tell you,
hey, plot the image, and
they'll describe it like this.
Translate x units to the left or the right
or three units up or down.
You'll sometimes see it like this,
but just recognize this is just saying
just take your x and
subtract five from it,
which means move five to the left.
And this just means take your y coordinate
and add three to it,
which means move three up.
And sometimes they'll ask you,
hey, what's the new coordinate?
Or sometimes they'll ask you
to plot something like that,
but just realize that it's
all the same underlying idea.